let's do another problem involving
inflection points and concativity and
minimum points and maximum points and
see if we can get a little bit more
intuition of everything that's going on
here so our friend akash sent me some
more problems that he would like to see
done and then these seem pretty good so
let's do them
so let's see the first problem it says
let's see it says g of x gives us this g
of x
is equal to
three
x to the
fourth
minus
four
x third to the third
plus
two
and it says determine where the graph oh
boy the phone is ringing
phone is ringing i don't know who that
is so i'm not going to answer that phone
anyway it's probably probably a
telemarketer but anyway so it says
determine where the graph of the given
function is increasing decreasing
concave up and concave down then sketch
it so essentially it says just figure
out everything about this function and
then draw it
so let's let's what what what's the
first thing we should do well let's
figure out all of the critical points
well what are the critical points those
are the points where the the function
either has a
zero slope so it's it's kind of flat at
those points or it has no derivative so
it's either a zero derivative or no
derivative
how do we figure those out well first we
have to figure out the derivative and
set it equal to zero so what's the
derivative
g prime
of x
is equal to let's see this is 12
x to the third
minus 12
x squared plus 0. so that's the first
derivative and we're going to deal with
the second derivative so let me just
write it down right now so what's the
second derivative
maybe i'll do that another color just
for fun
g prime prime of x
since where our brains are in derivative
mode let's just do that so it's 36
x squared
minus
minus 24
x
so let's figure out the critical points
or when the slope is equal to zero so
i'll call them cps
critical i'll just write down critical
critical
so to find the critical points we set
the first derivative equal to zero we're
just trying to figure out when does the
slope equal zero so let me do it in the
first derivative color that i chose
so let's set 12x
12 x to the third
minus 12
x squared is equal to zero
see we could factor out a 12x squared so
we get
12
x squared times x
minus 1
is
equal to 0.
and so what values of x make this equal
to zero well x could either be zero
because then this term would be zero
so we either get x is equal to zero
or x minus one is equal to zero
x minus one is equal to zero or x is
equal to one right add 1 to both sides
of that
so there we have we have we have two
points where we know that the slope of
the original function
is
0. and let's figure out what they are
whether those are minimum points maximum
points or inflection points or whatever
so let's uh let's take the point x is
equal to zero first
so first of all let's just know what the
coordinate is what's g of zero
so just so we know what the points are
so g
of zero is equal to what
g of 0 0 0 2
and what's g of 1
g of 1 is equal to what
3
minus 4
minus ones this was one
so actually let's let's graph that
let's graph it
so if
this is i'll draw it big
because this one seems like it might be
nuanced
let me draw it there
so that's on my y-axis
that's my y-axis
and then let's say that
no no let me actually i'm going to do
something
different let me draw my y-axis
let me draw it here
that's my y-axis
and this is my x-axis
that's my x-axis
and so what are the points that are the
critical points
i'll do them in yellow no loom and brown
so these are the two critical points so
one is zero comma two so this is zero
and let's say this is
let's say that this is two right here
so this is that right there is the point
zero
comma two
and the other interesting point is 1
comma 1. so this is 1 y this is about 1.
the other point is 1 comma 1.
so this is 1 comma 1.
drop down here 1
comma 1. so those are our critical
points so let's figure out if these are
inflection points or whatever so what is
the second derivative at x is equal to 0
and i'll do that in the second
derivative color
so g
prime prime
of 0
is equal to let's put 0 here we get 36
times 0 minus 24 times 0 what's equal to
0.
so this must be since the second
derivative is 0 this is an inflection
point
that's right and what is an inflection
point just to give you the intuition
inflection point is when you go from
either being concave upwards to being
concave downwards or you're going from
concave downwards to concave upwards and
just as an intuition beyond that what if
what is concave upwards and downwards
concave upwards means that over that
interval so if you're kind of in a bowl
the slope is the slope is always
increasing that's what concave upward
means right
actually well i don't want to waste
space here because i think i might need
it but you know concave upward means
that and if you look at every point you
see the slope is negative there then
becomes less negative then it becomes
zero then becomes more positive even
more positive so the slope is increasing
the entire time you're concave upward
and then similarly the slope is
decreasing the entire time you're
concave downward
right because here the slope is really
high becomes a little lower
flattens out becomes a little negative
more negative so concave downward just
means the slope just
becomes more and more negative or
decreases and concave and an inflection
point having the second derivative equal
to zero just means you're switching from
either concave downwards to upwards or
vice versa so that's an inflection point
and what is g g what is the second
derivative at x is equal to one so this
is an inflection point right here
inflection point i'll
that's an inflection point so it's
neither a minimum or a maximum and then
what is
the the second derivative
at 1. g prime prime of 1
is equal to and we just care whether
it's positive or negative we don't
actually care about the actual value for
what we're trying to do here
so take the second order is 36 times 1
minus 24 so it equals 12.
so it's positive
right it's a positive number so that
means it's concave upwards
so what do we know we know definitely
that around 1 1
we are concave upwards
so we know around 1 1 we're concave
upwards
we're concave upwards
around 1 1.
and i show that the graph keeps
increasing after that point and you can
try i mean you could see that you know
the the second derivative sorry the
first derivative is zero at that point
and for any value greater than x the
first derivative is positive right you
put any number here you put number any
number here greater than one and you're
going to get a positive value so you
know that the function is increasing
past one and it stays concave upwards
past one because you could put any
number here greater than one and it
keeps increasing we know this is an
inflection point but there's something
interesting here
in order to kind of
we know this inflection point and we
also know that the derivative here is
zero so
if at this point it must be kind of
flattish
right
the derivative is here and that it's not
kind of flattest it's actually flat but
the tangent line is a horizontal line at
that point the derivative is zero so in
order for
in order for the slope here to be flat
and in order for here the slope was
negative so at some point we must have
another inflection point over here so an
inflection point is any point where the
second derivative is zero so let's see
if we can find another point where the
second derivative is zero
and sometimes people don't even go over
these non-critical inflection points but
i like to because it kind of tells you
when the when the curve kind of kind of
changes direction a little bit or
changes its curvature so let's let's
find all of the points when that equals
zero this is the second derivative we're
dealing with now
so if we have 36
x squared minus 24 x
is equal to zero let's take out a 24 x
that's 24
x
times what's 36 divided by 24 that's
three halves right
three
halves x
minus one is equal to zero so the two
inflection points here either this term
is zero so we get x is equal to zero
did i do that right
24
divide this to this right 24 36 over 24
right three halves or
three halves x
three halves x
is equal to one i just said this is
going to be equal zero add one to both
sides and then you get x
is equal to two-thirds so there we have
it our intuition curve was correct there
was there's another inflection point at
x is equal to two-thirds
and when x is equal to two-thirds and we
could try to solve for it let's see
let's see it's two-thirds well it's too
too much trouble but two-thirds is
around here some point so we have
another inflection point we have to be
exact we have another inflection point
someplace around here where the graph
changes its curvature again
so here it's concave upwards then it
goes
at this inflection point x is two thirds
i don't know what the y value is you can
evaluate it
it turns into concave downwards
it becomes concave downwards
it flattens out there and then the slope
is 0 here but this is also an inflection
point so then it becomes concave upwards
again
so i'll do concave upwards in another
color so then it becomes concave upwards
again
so the graph is going to look something
like that where the yellow is the
interval over which is concave downwards
this is an inflection let me draw the
inflection points i'll put an x
that's an inflection point and then when
x is equal to two-thirds that was an
inflection point this is a minimum point
where we are concave
and some people don't even worry about
this inflection point but it's important
to realize that that there was a little
interval here where we were going
concave downwards and and and the
intuition what's the intuition there
well we know we're concave upwards here
and we're nowhere we're concave upwards
here but in order for this to be an
inflection point it must have switched
from concave downwards so we know we're
concave downwards here but if this is
concave downwards there must have been
an inflection point where we switch
where you switch from concave downwards
back to concave upwards again and our
intuition correct there is one at x is
equal to two-thirds
and just to not be the dead horse but
what are the inflection points where the
second derivative is equal to zero
so that's the graph and and i think that
that that that was a fairly instructive
problem so i thank akash for for sending
that to us see you in the next video